les tensions avec la Chine l'ont fait
craindre l'agression russe de l'Ukraine
nous l'a montrait des ennemis de
l'Europe ont la mamie sur l'accès aux
matières premières stratégiques dont
nous avons besoin pour faire face à nos
dépendances vous nous proposez un plan
extraction européenne transformation
européenne récupération des efforts qui
doivent être durables et en adéquation
avec le pacte vert il faut aider les
filières européennes avoir le jour ce
structurer se développer face à une
concurrence déloyale d'entreprises
soutenues par des états souvent
autoritaires Madame la Commissaire c'est
des points que vous avez évoqué et nous
le savons nous devrons faire face aussi
aux enjeux sociétaux que posent
l'extraction des matières premières en
Europe nous devons nous assurer que la
mise en oeuvre de cette stratégie
prennent en compte les réalités
territoriales et les exigences
environnementales la demande mondiale
sur les matières premières stratégiques
va être multipliée par 5 d'ici et 2050
nous savons que les ressources
européennes ne suffiront pas vous l'avez
dit et la commission multiplier les
accords des accords qui crispent aussi
parce qu'ils mettent parfois nos
entreprises qui respectent nos principes
et nos législations en concurrence avec
des États aux considération opposées
mais parce que toutes ces questions
interrogent nous devons continuer à
aller de l'avant avec un travail
efficace un travail de négociation qui
doit impliquer toutes les parties
prenantes un travail de concertation
plus transparent Madame la Commissaire
avec ce débat c'est bien plus que notre
économie que nous devons protéger c'est
notre autonomie que nous devons affirmer
et concrétiser